really can't fart right now hi I'm
Garrett and I'm Nikki we're fascinated
by how other people live so we're gonna
try and find some really interesting
living situations and live their
experience in a totally different
lifestyle to see which ones will bring
us closer together or push us further
apart
this week we're living in an Earthship
it's like a friendship but made out of
Earth instead of friends hi my name is
Michael Reynolds we have a company
called airship biotech sure and we are
developing sustainable off-grid
independent autonomous buildings all
over the world I've been working in this
direction for almost 50 years
hey guys welcome to ership biotech sure
my name is Ryan hey Ryan I'm here it
this is an Earthship this is inertia
right ships I don't know what that word
even really means it sounds a little
highfalutin and hippie-dippy Earthship
makes it sound like a group of aliens
landed on earth and decided to like
blend in with humans it looks like it's
gonna be the nicest house Nikki and I
have stayed in today I'm really excited
about that
but why are all these places in the
desert every human has to address six
issues one is comfortable shelter that
doesn't use fossil fuel one is
electricity water something to do with
their sewage food and all humans these
days produce garbage and whether we like
it or not we'd have to come up with
something to do with it so we have made
a vessel that we call the airship that
addresses all six of those points here
we are well it's warm in here oh my gosh
there's a garage with like plants in it
plants power system gray water system
the gray water system is gonna take care
of the water that comes from the sink of
the showers that goes into the planters
taking it through a filter and running
it to the toilet so before it even gets
out there has been used like three times
for attitude Wow these this is for
ventilation whoa now you're exchanging
the air your cooling space down this is
your thermostat apparently you have to
help your house breathe which is an
interesting thing I've never thought
about it's very practical in like I
think they grow their own vegetables and
know how to like reuse their water
notice the solar panels that lie
the front of the building uh-huh those
are coming into the charge controller
that's taking all the sunshine going
through the algorithms turning it into
power so it's all solar correct all
solar a very efficient house and we're
only in the garage I'm really excited to
have something that actually resembles a
house and doesn't have any sort of like
labor associated with it it sounds like
we'll learn a little bit about how this
house is new and futuristic but also
like we will enjoy creature comforts we
do have a flat-screen TV there we have
Wi-Fi so we're trying to gear it towards
people that aren't familiar with their
ships and then they come into one really
oh it's built out of tires and bottles
and cans and all sorts of repurposed
materials and this is a full kitchen a
full kitchen as well yes this gorgeous -
my goodness
yeah copper countertops custom built
cabinetry so it's all built on site so
people are supposed to be able to build
their own Earthship that's pretty cool
as somebody who likes to build stuff I'd
love to learn about how they built these
earthships I didn't really have a desire
to build my own home in my relationship
I'm not the crafty one I'm the more
let's play video games and eat at great
restaurants so the master bedroom is
down here to the left oh my gosh this is
enormous look at all the closets closets
closets closets and a bathroom we have
towels laid out for you shampoo shower
gel conditioner look at this oh my gosh
it's like stone shower we'll have to
work on adjustable showerheads
yeah I can see all the way to the
mountains though over the shower curtain
so I'm showering looking at the
mountains oh no I just kicked this thing
over did he just break that he can fix
it we got a camera - so yeah I'm a
little nervous that because we don't
have any like activities
we're gonna go stir-crazy we'll probably
bump heads again because I'm not sure
there's a whole lot to do in this desert
how many earthships are hearing at about
76 you saved 77 with that one and I'd
say at least 50 of them are permanent
residences Wow the thrill in my thrust
is seeing more and more people heavily
we're setting here in a building that's
not hooked up to any grid as food
growing doesn't even have a heater of
any kind in it this is available to the
world and this could change the world
that's so cool it's fun
like I said it's a lot of work but I'm
building my freedom thank you so much
thanks a lot right okay let's go
it's an exciting this is like the most
beautiful house we lived in sorry
everybody else Billy you should take the
master bedroom because you broke the
bathroom all right I'm gonna take this
one okay have fun
mmm well the space my broken shower I
don't know how I'm gonna fix that well I
worry about that later
I don't like that skinny cat one bit we
go take it to Nikki's room she likes
cats
if you just rearranged decor but fine I
will gladly accept this cat thank you
this great view wake up - yeah I think
we're gonna be very comfortable here I
think so - hey look at how much space
there is this place it's huge and I can
send all the way over here and you
Garrett can be over there this is by far
the nicest place we've stayed in we've
got all these plants and lemongrass
everything smells amazing and alive even
though it's December in the middle of
the desert hopefully we remember to do
all the things we're supposed to do to
take care of the earth strip because
it's like a living breathing thing we're
literally in a house of recycled garbage
and you cannot tell it's still so much
nicer than my house in Los Angeles so
there are all these windows and things
that we have opening and closing I know
there's a combination that will make us
freeze to death
hopefully we haven't gotten wait really
I know out there is just a greenhouse
because I can't see through it cuz it's
dark all I see is myself it makes me
feel like someone's there
it's nighttime Nikki and I are both
working tomorrow we're gonna learn a lot
more about how to actually build it this
is fascinating I don't know how it all
works it's amazing that it does and I'm
very happy tonight Iggy are you
comfortable
[Music]
is this mall amazing plants there's that
demon cat it's very bright in my room I
didn't even leave my alarm
[Music]
Nikki huh let's make food oh yeah we're
gonna be cool if we were growing
avocados out there and then we would
just be like I think that's like Cheers
breakfast in our home probably the best
ones we made - it's like 20 degrees
outside but we need to reason here
[Music]
well I just got water it's hot like a
full Tower of the Sun yeah I can see
what we grow bananas in here I'm not a
banana here we are at the great world of
community and we are working on a house
under construction today sounds like you
want to do some adobe plaster
it's so dry here in the desert but this
dirt is pretty much a hundred percent
clay so we're gonna sift the rocks and
all the big stuff out and make get more
fine you done one shovel you Nikki
no never had to hide a body or anything
no have you know this will be the Adobe
mixer let's start with about half a
bucket of water now we're gonna put in
two full buckets of sand
it's like making cookies
Oh dog oku dogs I think initially you
all may want to kind of slap and smear
every wall surface is finished I always
done like class slap and smear it up oh
my gosh it's like building a sandcastle
all right okay yeah I'm getting making
progress well we're doing a pretty bad
job but we're learning it's very
satisfying like literally filling up
holes
special edition construction Niki comes
with a Hawk a trawl and a winning
attitude I'm feeling a lot more
confident the trawl so it's like a skill
I've just picked up until about two
hours ago I had no idea what Adobe was
or how people used it but now I've mixed
it and I've laid it I have helped to
build a tiny piece of this hawk
I think it looks great really yeah great
nice work yeah I paid the price for it
what happened I don't know thanks Bill
it doesn't I'm good luck with the rest
of this wall yeah I don't know what
we'll do without you so what do we have
here so we're at the Phoenix Earthship
and this is where Mike took the concept
of the earth ships and went wild with it
and made it really eccentric and a lot
of artistic details in this building
this direction puts power to the people
it empowers them to take their energy
from the Sun it's right there it's free
people should have the right to
encounter the natural phenomena of this
planet to sustain themselves man this is
like a like a jungle maze right so this
is actually where the grey water starts
from the sink of the shower in the
bathroom here birds there's birds
there's birds there's birds - cockatiels
into parakeet
this is straight out of sunlight this is
celibacy is it TV yes sir
we have even gone out until like the
greenhouse part of it you can't argue
with bananas in your living room in the
winter you can't argue with the Sun
heating your house these things can be
machined so there's a long way to go so
the house is about 5,300 square feet and
about 2,000 of that is greenhouse space
there really is no limit to what you can
create
right and we're just scratching the
surface and let's possible we're going
to Puerto Rico in a bunt because their
power is down their waters down their
infrastructures down this building has
its own infrastructure we're gonna build
a building that cannot be blown away by
any hurricane like living in a house can
be exciting and ever-changing it grows
with you you take care of it that takes
care of you yeah this concept is a way
to stay alive longer so after work today
we found that our rental car had some
trouble with the tires so Guerra had to
drive it into town and get it sorted out
he's not gonna be back for another like
two hours so I started clicking dinner
so I'm gonna pick a few spring when he's
done
like I had to go drive that and then
drive it back at the end I was just
really exhausted today is been really
fun I'm very fascinated by Earth trips
we got to see another earth ship today
which was beyond anything I could
comprehend Phoenix is like something out
of a sci-fi movie I can't imagine what
it would be like to complete your own
earth ship it's a very simple in
practice but also a lot of hard work
that's got to be an amazing
[Music]
good morning plants
good morning Earthship morning
we did it we lived in an Earthship it
was so much more comfortable than I
thought it would be especially since
it's made out of garbage because this is
such a comfortable house to live in it's
been very easy for Garret night to be
roommates
no I can breathe this is like the first
time where I'm walking away thinking oh
yeah I'd maybe like to take some of
these principles and apply them to my
own house someday
this is the Earthship village Ecology's
Eve this is what we're trying to
basically get an Earthship apartment
style complex going so you have people
living together working together towards
building a better future as far as the
homes but also growing food together
living together and just sharing the
space and coming up with a better way
for the future that's kale like I think
when people think about sustainable
living that's very good for the earth
they think that they have to relinquish
some comfort and we did not the idea of
building my own earthships sounds so
much fun that like maybe even when I
retire that's what I'll do they'll just
builder ships like I can make showers
that will fit me everything that I've
learned here makes me so excited to
think about the possibilities of Earth
ships and what could be next
by Earthship next week on homebodies
welcome to our mansion we're finally
going to imagine this is my Richie Rich
moment this mansion is so big it's like
the American dream right this is a
lifestyle that everyone must experience
this is it
[Music]